o lado pessoal aqui quem fala é o dark
sido muito bem vindos a mais um vídeo
mostrado de que o laser contra melhor
segurar um vídeo laser contra 143
milhões de visualizações é muito livre
mas conquistar a meta do time life
importância relativa que encomendará
outros lesados e eu vou tentar mesmo
tendo mais brega podiam tocar mas
enquanto espera eu vou tentar fazer
alguns testes com esses players e um dos
testes vai ser tentar fazer pipoca com
esse milho eu duvido que vá acontecer eu
acho que não mas vamos tentar eu comprei
um valão preto 8 funciona melhor em
coisas pretas portanto eu investi pintar
logo a caneta preta eu vou tentar usar o
sananduva não pretende ver o que
acontece mas eu vou tentar fazer aqui
uma coisa engraçada que tem 63 valor
inscrever sua resposta dos três mas ao
mesmo tempo e as partes do país
mas nós não vamos faltar capital tem
opção
nós vamos usar a mega arma super
contente mas não faltou uma lente
supersônica do rio que concentra um
ponto o foco principal no meio eu acho
que ele vai ter muito mais força aqui
também conforme primeiro esta entre
funciona vai no colo tanque também
quinta o russo foi muito generoso quanto
mais fino portanto eu acho coisa vai ser
melhor né
fiquem por aí e vamos ver o que acontece
ele inclusive também a primeira coisa
que vamos fazer então é tentar acender
os postos vão tentar atender também à
lupa e depois com lupa e ver se é mais
rápido foi mais ficou mais densa e
máquina pública duas vezes ele tentou
dar provas muito rápido e foi levado com
muita muita muita pressão muita refinado
e cai 3 do spu mais votado esta turma tá
quase está quase a cena muita demanda é
muito grande
a cair 3 2 1 vai todo mundo porque o
cinto violência mais ou menos perfis em
sua loja que não dá roubar eu acho que
estão indo equipe não resultados por si
me inspiraram encontrar 321 pai sol só
tá muito mais rápido na lei está muito
mais rápido descobrir de que arma
secreta para fora uma falta e além do 8
país próxima vítima vai ser o nosso
balão preto
o tempo que eu vou tentar agora alinhar
vista o fim de que da mesma está apenas
com um não funciona e 32 um pai muito
rápido mas olhar um pouco mais devagar
ai 4 ventou aí mais devagar ainda é
muito mais eficaz nesse caso não
funcionou muito bem em alguma coisa
errada aqui no ano passado que não vamos
ver o resto como outros 14
deixo aqui uma 3321 ray olha olha como
eu vou tentar ficar aqui uns lutadores
vamos ver o que aconteceu estou tentado
escapar do incêndio
o sol com a peneira mas abre um buraco
muito pequeno muito provavelmente o
deixará 15.600 qualquer mas vamos tentar
mais uma vítima fatal na curva que ele
era o pai só como eu é preto com
vantagem para tratar um olho aí a fome
o tiro o chapéu e com certeza muito
barato e já é bem potente imaginamos que
estão pressionados falam inglês a opel
vai ter q tem q newman tenham qualquer
coisa eu encomendei um dos mais de cinco
mil e outros 10 mil tanto bem muita
coisa que tenta pôr do sol próximo à
vítima então vai ser o nosso inclusivo e
saibamos positivo acredita que uma
daquelas velas tribo que fazem física
estamos trabalhando em estádios e com o
perfil ideal a jornada deste gesto
importante vir aqui na sua experiência e
design é colar em armamento na curva e
toda a gente do povo temperatura de 32
bull vai contar com a companhia a ele
o botafogo eu acho que esta final mais
do papo que mo incluiu não saibamos
espaço eu vou esperar um pouco mais que
eu acho que seguia ter é capaz de se
ingressar no setor sempre não é possível
muito dura muito do falcão não consegue
aprender a trocar 12 minutos 24 178
focos querem foi 8 segundos é possível
que uma hora
assumindo que toca toca ao crescimento
vídeo eu vou tentar discutir um
cigarrinho próxima etapa a meta é 100
mil e olha vou tentar sempre toca porque
tem contas a pagar um juro que eu vou
fazer é só fazer um pequeno teste com um
único menino e depois vamos tentar ver o
que acontece até o momento comemora é
algo que vou ter que entrar
obrigatoriamente preto né pelo leão não
concentrá-lo qualquer forma tudo pronto
mesmo com pinta preta o laser 32 mas
[Música]
nunca muito minguta atrair aquela fumaça
gostosa domingo o doca olha tem partidas
aula olhar e gostoso não xuxa tira
[Música]
qualquer pessoa única nesse ataque todo
montado por muito difícil de montar a
estrutura e alinhar mais funciona só em
outras conseguem ver mas já começa a ser
um fundo
[Música]
o pessoal já estava pronto a luz apagada
e agora vou deixar aqui para gravar 30
minutos criança esperando o que vai
acontecer comenta henry o que você já
assunto para a pipoca é tão barato e
volta como e já vai um vídeo como tj
aconselhar sobre o poeta
[Música]
a taxa da muita pipoca
mas mesmo assim acho que não vou voltar
em dez minutos
[Música]
o álbum traz dez minutos
o tuaw o do suor
depois de 30 minutos indo atrás meia
hora fica maior
mais um flop pessoal isto deu mesmo uma
pipoca disse concluindo e agora vamos
provar então a nossa hipótese é o pior é
que só podemos fazer uma cerveja não dá
prazo de muitas eu acho a não ser que
tenha vários maridos né levantamento é
boa 321 normal
bom muito bom ou excelente e talento
para poder analisar o atual objetivo
concluído nós conseguimos fazer a nossa
pipoca e já estava encontrando se
arrastam millais decidiu eu vou tentar
usar o nosso bayern contra os caiu
quando o que vai acontecer não partir
daí eu acho que tem que ter um pouco
duro é porque não tem mais poder do que
vai acontecer alguma coisa vamos tentar
por exemplo não tem milagre não ter dois
vídeos provavelmente não viram e regina
vaz podem ser diferente